nous sommes dans la petite ville
frontalière de campbellton le pont
enjambe la rivière restigouche qui
sépare le nouveau brunswick et le québec
qui lie à 7 ans le docteur jean robert
ngola originaire de la république
démocratique du congo a décidé de venir
s'y installer
seulement population mon peuple
le médecin compte plus de 2000 patients
à sa clinique en plus de travailler aux
urgences de l'hôpital régional de
campbellton le matin du 27 mai il reçoit
un diagnostic positif à la coved 19 et
sa vie tourne au cauchemar
oui non inscrits à la région à peine
quatre heures plus tard le premier
ministre du nouveau-brunswick annonce
dans sa conférence de presse quotidienne
sur la copie de 19 que le virus est de
retour est-ce qu'il est temps de faire
des enquêtes étaient ce mois les
patients
quelles sont les preuves que le patient
us à deux mois où les autres collègues
orissa deux mois en soirée un deuxième
diagnostic tombe sa fille de quatre ans
est elle aussi positive
le docteur ngola reçoit une lettre de
suspension immédiate sans solde de son
employeur
la régie de santé vitalité quelques
jours plus tard la gendarmerie royale du
canada et saisit de la sphère et débute
une enquête responsable médecin
nous avons ouvert des poursuites
criminelles
la province lui reproche de ne pas
s'être isolé après un retour de voyage
au québec fait entre les 12 et 13 mai
une urgence familiale oblige jean robert
ngola à se rendre à montréal
il doit aller chercher sa fille la mère
de l'enfant devant assister à des
funérailles en afrique
il affirme avoir appelé la ligne
d'urgence coe vite du nouveau brunswick
et du québec
cinq jours avant son voyage et demander
à votre tour des problèmes de plomberie
fille le voyage dure moins de 30 heures
en tout il quitte l'hôpital de
campbellton après son quart de travail
est fait le trajet de nuit presque sans
s'arrêter récupère sa fille chez son
frère et le lendemain rencontre des
collègues à trois rivières pour un
entretien d'embauché e'lara passent la
frontière du nouveau-brunswick en soirée
mon frère a fait son test est négatif
j'ai appelé mes deux médecins que je
rencontre dans leur coin il ya personne
selon cet épidémiologiste de
l'université dalhousie il est peu
probable que le docteur ngola est
contracté le virus au québec mais pas
impossible il ne nous a pas été possible
d'obtenir les résultats de l'enquêté
épidémiologique de la santé publique du
nouveau brunswick
la médecin hygiéniste en chef a décliné
notre demande d'entrevue
mais ce que l'on sait par ailleurs c'est
que le docteur ngola n'était pas le seul
professionnel de la santé à avoir
traversé la frontière durant la pandémie
hollande a cité 9 % des gens qui
travaillent soit le talent et la soie au
chr qui sont des employés réguliers et
qui voyage qui avaient lieu de résidence
et aux employés s'ajoutent les patients
un quart d'entre eux viennent également
du québec
le pdg du réseau de santé vitalité
l'employeur du docteur ngola affirme
aujourd'hui ne pas être en mesure de
dire si le docteur est à l'origine de
l'éclosion
sur le post à tuer le patient
de plus en raison d'une pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre aiguë dans le nord de la
province
plusieurs hôpitaux dépendent de docteur
de l'extérieur pour faire des cadeaux
travail ces docteurs ne sont pas non
plus tenu de s'isoler mais dans le cas
du docteur ngola la situation différente
selon son employeur étant un médecin
régulier il ne bénéficiait pas de
l'exemption de 40 n avait aucune
pression pour asus passion la suspension
était déterminé parce que dr en gros lot
à quitter la province nous est faux mais
il ne sait pas et jallet les avocats du
docteur ngola allègue au contraire que
le médecin a été pris à partie par les
autorités parce qu'il est noir parce que
on appelait on blâme et on a appelé à la
guerre criminelle sans même avoir fait
une enquête au préalable sans même avoir
fait le travail qui était nécessaire
parce qu'on n'a pas été transparent avec
les populations
on n'a pas été honnête on n'aura pas dit
qu'il y avait des gens qui dit les les
docteurs blanc entrait et sortait le
premier ministre du nouveau-brunswick
qui n'a pas eu besoin de nommer le
docteur ngola il était déjà coupable aux
yeux de la population
quelques heures avant la conférence de
presse du 27 mai son nom sa photo son
adresse se retrouvent dans les médias
sociaux
le docteur ngola est convaincu qu'il y
ait une fuite délibérée de ses
informations personnelles
le premier ministre de même que vitalité
disent de leur côté avoir fait des
enquêtes internes et affirme ne rien
avoir à se reprocher au bout du compte
cette situation a coûté du vide un
restigouche en plus de contaminer une
quarantaine de personnes les docteurs en
valeur l'équipe d'avocats du docteur
angola a maintenant l'intention de
poursuivre la province beaucoup de
problèmes présomption d'innocence le
droit partial
c'est nécessaire ici que ceci ne se
reproduise pas jean-robert ngola a
aujourd'hui quitté la région et
pratiquer la médecine dans une clinique
de louiseville au québec depuis début
août je me consacre que je fais mon rôle
de médecin le docteur et sommet à
comparaître en cour de campbellton en
octobre pour une infraction à la loi sur
les mesures d'urgence
la grc continue son enquête de son côté
et selon les avocats du docteur ngola
aucune accusation criminelle ne serait
déposée contre lui
jean-robert ngola et sa fille et est
asymptomatique